brett good evening today the taliban
called on the united states not to
encourage the afghan people to leave
their country though thousands continue
to flee their brutal rule
chaos outside the gates of kabul's
airport
another day of desperate civilians
trying to flee as the taliban issued new
rules for the country
afghans without foreign passports will
no longer be permitted to go to the
airport american troops are scheduled to
withdraw from afghanistan in one week
and the taliban says the august 31st
withdrawal date cannot be extended
we are sending a message to the
americans again to evacuate their
citizens by this date because they have
the means to do so they have plans and
the airport is with them and they have
to transfer all the forces and
contractors who have relation with
foreigners
in their secret meeting yesterday cia
director william burns and taliban
leader abdelgani baradar held the
highest level face-to-face conversation
between the taliban and the americans
since the group took control of
afghanistan
coordinating the withdrawal of u.s
forces comes amid new warnings today
about human rights abuses by the taliban
u.n official michel bakley spoke to the
human rights council tuesday saying
she's received credible reports of
things ranging from restrictions for
women to summary executions a
fundamental red line will be the
taliban's treatment of women and girls
and respect for their rights to liberty
freedom of movement education
self-expression and employment guided by
international human rights norms
despite these reports the taliban wants
countries to keep their embassies open
in kabul something that could be a tough
sell amid these human rights violations
brett
trey yanks early wednesday morning and
doha cutter trey thanks hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else